joining us now treasury secretary steven
mnuchin mr secretary thanks
welcome back to fox news sunday thanks
brett it's great to be with you
i'd like to start with where the
coronavirus stimulus bill
the next iteration stands in the
negotiations
as of right now well brett the president
i couldn't be more pleased with the way
the economic plan is working we've
injected three trillion dollars into the
economy
people thought we'd get 25 unemployment
fortunately it never came close to that
we're
down to 8.4 but the president i believe
we should do more stimulus we have about
seven and a half million jobs that we
need to get back until we're back to
where we were
and we want to help small businesses we
want to help
businesses that are particularly
impacted by this and we'll continue to
work on
proposed new legislation so what's the
sticking point does speaker pelosi want
this do you believe
well i think you know in my discussions
with the speaker where we're really
stuck is both on certain policy issues
but more importantly on the top line
the speaker has refused to sit down and
negotiate unless we agree to something
like a two and a half trillion dollar
deal in advance and brett as you know we
put three trillion dollars into the
economy when the economy was completely
shut down
we've now reopened the economy well
let's let's do a more targeted bill now
if we need to do more in 30 days we'll
continue to
do more but let's not hold up the
american workers
and american businesses that need more
support so on the logistics will senate
republicans move a so-called skinny bill
next week
i'd like to call it a more targeted bill
not a skinny bill but yes our
our expectation is we'll move forward
with that next week
what exactly did you agree with the
speaker on government funding
well the good news brett is the speaker
and i have agreed we both don't want to
see a government shutdown
so we've agreed that we are going to do
a clean cr we'll do this separately from
the
the cares act negotiations we're having
the appropriations
staff the four corners meet and go
through some specific details on it but
the good news is we've agreed agreed on
a clean cr
and i hope by the end of the week we can
begin moving forward with that because
that that's important to the american
people
see our continuing resolution how long
would that government funding extension
last
through election day some other timeline
we haven't agreed on the specific
details but my expectation it would be
through the beginning of december that's
what we did this year
we had one through december we then
needed another one into the beginning of
next year and then and then we had final
appropriation
so for now the most important thing is
to make sure at the end of the month we
don't shut down the government
and we get something past the election
no mr secretary there has been some
vocal criticism from republicans
about you negotiating saying in essence
that you're giving away the store the
president's joked
that he doesn't know whether you're a
democrat or republican here's the wall
street journal editorial board
republicans in the age of donald trump
don't know what they stand for on
economics
treasury secretary steven mnuchin is a
keynesian whose idea of compromise is
half of whatever mrs pelosi wants
saying it's a down payment on her
election agenda
your reaction to that criticism and
would it be better to bring the
president
in have him get everybody in the oval
office and and try to hammer out a deal
well let me first say i don't take the
wall street journal editorials
personally sometimes they have good
things to say and sometimes it's
nonsense like this case
as i've said before i don't agree to
anything that i don't review with the
president
i speak to the president daily our
economic plan
got us back to an extraordinary
reopening
of the economy and the president wanted
us to move forward with three trillion
dollars of spending that's what we did
it's helped an enormous amount of
american businesses and american workers
and the answer is the president
constantly has not only his economic
team
in the oval office but now mark meadows
and i have been
on the phone with mitch mcconnell and
the senate republicans
every single day mark and i obviously
speak to kevin mccarthy
and the republicans in the house but let
me be clear any legislation requires
bipartisan support
we couldn't be more proud the last two
bills in the senate
100 to zero and 96 to zero so
i find that anything other than complete
bipartisan support from both sides
most experts looked at friday's latest
jobs report as positive as you mentioned
strong beating expectations here's how
the former vice president characterized
it friday though
the report reinforces the worst
fears and painful truths the economic
inequities that began before the
downturn
have only worsened under this failed
presidency
when the crisis started we all hope for
a few months of a shutdown would be
followed by a rapid economic turnaround
no one thought they'd lose their job for
good
your reaction to that well the former
vice president and the former president
had one of the longest economic
recessions that we've had
uh under president trump we had the
lowest unemployment we've had we've had
the best economy we've ever had
and to no fault of any american
businesses
the president made the very difficult
decision to shut down
the entire u.s economy because of this
terrible
covid disease now the good news is we've
reopened it
so again let me just say people thought
we'd have
30 40 million people unemployed we never
did that
because of the bipartisan support
putting money into the economy
we're now down to 8.4 and the
president's gonna get it back down
to three or four percent where it was
before all of this
uh in the beginning of next year when
he's reelected so 1.4 million jobs added
in august as you mentioned unemployment
rate down to 8.4 percent
at looking right now in the current
trajectory what do you think it'll be by
election day
i think you're going to see it continue
to go down we're going to have one more
employment number this month that you're
going to see i think you're going to see
another good number
you're going to see a phenomenal third
quarter gdp
some people think it's it's it's going
to be in the neighborhood of 30 35
percent
uh whether it's 25 30 35 percent you're
going to see
this is the american economy rebounding
this is american business
people know when the government gets out
of the way
and we let american business work and
with a little support from industries
that are hardest to hit and that's why
we want more legislation
this economy will fully recover and the
president's job and my job is not done
until everybody gets back to work i want
to go overseas the country's still in
the iran nuclear deal say the u.s
doesn't have standing
to do snap back sanctions can and will
the u.s
go alone on this we will so let me just
say
we don't agree with that technical
analysis
at the u.n i think our allies understand
that selling arms to iran right now
would be perhaps the worst decision that
one can do
we're talking about the number one
country in the middle east that has
created terror around the middle east uh
and the president is determined one
they're never going to have a nuclear
weapon and two we're not going to let
them
hurt their friend hurt our friends in
the area
you were not on that trip to france with
the president that's the focus of the
atlantic
piece that has received so much
attention in the past few days
administration pushback on the record
but unnamed sources confirming parts
of that story at least parts of the
account have you ever heard
the president use any of that language
about veterans dead
or alive ever being around him
quite the contrary this president
supports the military
in an unbelievable way he's created more
funding
to rebuild the military that was one of
the things he campaigned on and he
delivered
i've been with the president to
arlington on memorial day let me tell
you i've listened to him there i've
watched him go visit
sites there i've been with him to the
anniversary of world war ii it was a
very emotional
experience so no quite the contrary i
think this president
has enormous respect for the military
and for the generals and i've i've been
at the tank
at the pentagon with him i've been at 9
11 at the pentagon with him
this president respects and supports the
u.s military
the president also says he's against the
cancel culture
but do you think it's right for him to
call for the firing of a reporter who
has unnamed sources who confirm parts of
that story
right i really don't know anything about
that so it's just not something i can
comment on
okay well he's tweeted about it and
obviously he he says that he wants
a reporter who happens to work here at
fox fired
i've been busy on economic issues to be
honest with you i i focus on a lot of a
lot of things and as i said on the
military
i've always heard him to be 150 percent
supportive
i'm just not aware of the the issues
that you're talking about last thing
the cbo says the national debt will
reach about the size of the u.s
economy by the end of the year i've
interviewed you many times
before and asked you about the growing
size of the debt you look at it's
approaching 27 trillion dollars
uh the deficit and the debt concern
you've always said it's quote
manageable but after this pandemic
if the president is reelected would you
see a second term
some serious administration plan to
address the debt
i would brad i think before we got into
covet i thought the debt was very
manageable we were having
extraordinary growth we were creating
growth that would pay down the debt over
time
unfortunately this china virus has cost
us trillions of dollars
and as i've said before this is like a
ward in a war you got to spend
whatever you need to spend so that's the
reason why we spent three trillion
dollars we'd spend another trillion
dollars
the speaker wants to just spend
unlimited amounts of money
i think the former vice president if he
were elected would have socialist
economic policies that would take the
debt out of control
but there's no question in a second term
once the economy is back
we will focus on this issue mr secretary
we appreciate your time
and happy labor day thank you